[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my new Star Wars rise of
Skywalker video for the Mandalorian and
baby Yoda I got a lot of questions about
them during my rise of Skywalker videos
so we'll break it down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing a
merch giveaway because they finally have
baby Yoda merch on sale all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite moment from the
Mandalorian tour rise of Skywalker on
the video obviously careful for spoilers
from Star Wars the rise of Skywalker as
well as the Mandalorian series you
really have to know what's going on with
baby Yoda during the events of that
series and what they're trying to set up
with that plot to understand what's
going on later in the timeline because
if you're not sure what's happening and
when it's happening in the timeline the
Mandalorian series takes place five
years after Return of the Jedi the
events of the new trilogy start about
thirty years after Return of the Jedi so
you have to assume it baby Yoda is
around fifty years old as they said
during season one of the Mandalorian he
be between 75 and 78 around the time
brides with Skywalker's happening the
Mandalorian is quite a bit younger than
baby Yoda though because he was around
seven or eight during the events of the
Clone Wars because you see the giant
separatist battle droids come and kill
his parents so during the events of the
new trilogy the Mandalorian would be in
his late 60s early 70s just for the sake
of comparison though Han Solo is about
66 during the events of force awakens he
looks way older than that just because
he's got a lot of city miles on him and
Harrison Ford is 73 when they're filming
that if they didn't use any of Marvel's
special D aging technology that they do
in the Marvel movies making the older
actors look quite a bit younger they did
it for Carrie Fisher just a little bit
but Luke Skywalker is about 53 54 during
the events of last Jedi he also looks a
lot older because in real life Mark
Hamill was 66 when they filmed that and
they also didn't use any special D aging
technology for him so even though the
Mandalorian himself underneath that
helmet paid
Pascal's character would be pretty old
he wouldn't be extremely old baby Yoda
has already shown us he's super powerful
he's been able to force choke people
exhibiting some sip ours has been able
to levitate the mud horn he's been able
to force heal people which is also a
power that we saw Ray used for the first
time during rise of Skywalker which
previously used to be like a god tier
Legends ability so if baby Oda is this
powerful why wouldn't he be around at
the age of 75 quite a bit older quite a
bit more powerful and physically just
have grown a little bit more so he's
actually physically larger in size
typical humanoid children that you see
during the prequels when Yoda's training
all those younglings are between the
ages of 7 & 8 when they start training
so if Yoda's Rayce matures at about the
same rate that humans do comparatively
by the time he's 70 75 almost 80 years
old he would definitely be ready to
start formal Jedi training and because
members of Yoda's race are always born
so innately powerful in the force and so
force sensitive he would probably be as
powerful if not way more powerful than
Anakin Skywalker was around the time of
Attack of the Clones after he'd had a
little bit of Jedi training under him
some of the abilities we've seen baby
Yoda use our abilities we've only seen
previously from adult Jedi and Sith so
you have to assume that he's way more
advanced way more powerful than any of
the Jedi you've seen before we don't
hear any mention of him during rise of
Skywalker Emperor Palpatine doesn't talk
about trying to track down any of the
other force sensitive people around the
galaxy he's only focused on tricking Rey
into killing him in hatred so that she
will fully become Sith and his force
spirit can enter her body and hopefully
I think the idea is that he wants to
take over her body and that he could
rule the galaxy through her form but
there's this whole subplot on the
Mandalorian right now about the Empire
the remnants of the empire through Moff
Gideon's character and all the territory
that he controls and troops using baby
Yoda to reestablish Imperial dominance
in the wake of the fall of the Empire
return of the Jedi so there's a lot of
missing timeline if they knew about him
then and he's such this topic of
interest for the former Empire then why
isn't the first-order looking for him
why isn't Emperor Palpatine talking
about him we're really still just in
season one of the Mandalorian series so
we're only just learning about the other
remnants of the Empire we just met moth
Gideon so we don't know who else is
working
with him besides dr. purging in the
cloning facility at Kamino
there was this whole subplot during rise
of Skywalker about Emperor Palpatine
saying that he'd been cloning Snoke this
whole time so using techniques he's
already been doing a measure of what it
seems like Moff Gideon is trying to do
with baby Yoda create a new army of
force-sensitive clones or at least use
some of his DNA to create humanoid
clones that are then force sensitive and
lived way longer in her way more
powerful and easily controllable but if
the Mandalorian runs four or five
seasons obviously this is just the
beginning of what their plans for baby
Yoda are but I like to think that Star
Wars at least in the end tries to be as
optimistic as possible
even though they kind of drag some
people through the mud on the way there
George Lucas is so utterly protective of
the way new Star Wars stories used the
Yoda character in Yoda's race that I
don't think he would allow Dave Filoni
his surrogate son in jon favreau to
create a new member of his race only to
then kill him off really quickly the
whole concept of his race is that they
represent one of the truest connections
to the force on a biological and
spiritual level the whole metaphor being
that the smallest tiniest creatures are
somehow the most innately powerful so
for the sake of argument let us assume
that baby Yoda is still alive in a well
during the events of the new trilogy
he's probably just still in the Outer
Rim territories living with the
Mandalorian who is much older now who
since the events of season 1 has
officially become his surrogate father
in a more official capacity and they
also have slowly been working to restore
the Mandalorian people along with the
other people of the Mandalorian clan in
addition to eventually restoring Yoda's
race but those are really really long
term goals
remember how rare it is for members of
Yoda's race to be born in the galaxy at
any given time there's really only one
or two like yeah ttle is the only other
one that we see during the prequels and
she actually left after Phantom Menace I
think the best explanation for why baby
Yoda isn't around during the events of
the new trilogy or during rise of
Skywalker at all why he's never
mentioned by any of the characters is
mostly that he's here on the other side
of the galaxy in the Outer Rim like
remember we saw them go to Tatooine
Tatooine is on the exact opposite side
of the galaxy from where Palpatine is on
X a goal in the Unknown Regions we don't
know exactly where that planet is we
just noticed in the unknown regions and
that's this part of space way up here
the reason why the first order probably
isn't trying to hunt him down or Emperor
Palpatine isn't trying to find baby Yoda
is probably because the only people who
knew of his existence during the events
of the Mandalorian series were Mothe
Gideon's men in his inner circle and
since then they've all either been
killed off by the Mandalorian trying to
protect baby Yoda or at some point
during the Mandalorian series they
switch sides and tried to help him like
dr. purging seems like he's going to
eventually help them in through their
actions they're probably able to either
erase all records of baby Yoda at least
all Imperial records or silence all the
people that would eventually seek to do
him harm so the for the most part he
literally and metaphorically flies under
the radar as he continues to grow up
living with the Mandalorian under his
protection you also have to assume that
they were creating the series in
thinking about creating the character
while they were actually filming and
working on rise of Skywalker so it was
probably too late in the game to
actually stuff him in and because they
spent so much time trying to keep a lid
on the secret of baby Oda being
introduced in the Mandalorian series
there's no merchandise they didn't put
him in any of the marketing so they
probably wanted to keep him out of rise
of Skywalker on purpose just to help
keep the secret but I think the idea is
presumably after the events of the rise
of Skywalker ending scene where Rey
berries Luke and Leia's lightsabers and
then names herself a Skywalker she sets
out on the task of finding other force
sensitive beings around the galaxy and
creating a new jedi temple with the help
of the Jedi Tech's which she's kept Finn
is a really good example of a new force
sensitive person now confirmed by the
filmmakers and by John boyega himself he
would probably wind up being one of her
first Padawans and no idea where broom
boy was when this was all happening or
if it even noticed that he was force
sensitive when they were on canto bite
but the whole idea of the new trilogy is
that there are all these force sensitive
people out there all over the place and
it's just on Rey to spend the rest of
her life finding them and rebuilding the
Jedi Order and eventually at some point
baby Yoda would cross paths with her
they would sense each other through the
force across the galaxy and keep in mind
even if he waited a couple years after
the events of rise of Skywalker he would
be rounding out aged 80 by the time that
happened eventually he would have to
find someone else to help take care of
baby Yoda if he was not already able to
take care of himself
so if yours
a little confused about what's going on
there is no baby Yoda or a Mandalorian
during rise of Skywalker anywhere there
is a minor easter egg in the background
of this giant fleet when all the ships
come to fight on X ago you see all these
different types of ships in the
background there is a ship right here
that looks like the same configuration
as the Mandalorians razor crest ship I
think it's safer to assume that baby
Yoda will eventually show up in the
movies set after the events of rise of
Skywalker everyone post your theories in
the comments below
where is baby Yoda hiding out during the
events of the new trilogy the
Mandalorian Episode 8 finale is gonna be
on Friday of course I'll post my video
for that I'll be doing more Mandalorian
bonus videos for season 2 and all that
stuff because they are about halfway
done filming season 2 right now
congratulations Alex Ramirez you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Star
Wars video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details
everyone click here for my brand new
Mandalorian episode 7 video and click
here for my Star Wars rise of Skywalker
top 20 WTF video thank you so much for
watching happy holidays merry Christmas
everyone
I'll see you guys tonight
you